how's it going everybody it's Warren and
today is a very exciting day because we
have our first leaked video and photos
of Marvel's phase four of the MCU Black
Widow started filming today we have our
first leaked photos of her on set we
have our first leaked photos of her
during a scene and we have some leaked
footage of a scene as well and again
it's really exciting because like I said
these are the first leaks that we've got
for phase four of the MCU so I'll show
the footage that we've got and the
leaked photos in this video but first I
want to say thank you all so much for
400,000 subscribers this is a dream come
true and I could not have done it
without you all I will announce the
giveaway winners and a solo video for it
later on this afternoon and of course
I'm starting a new giveaway as a way to
give back to you all at the 450,000
subscriber mark and the 500,000
subscriber mark I'll still be given away
Marvel Legends series items so be sure
to subscribe comment and like the video
so you can enter so as you can see we
have our first leaked footage and
there's no audio to it because it's
taken from very far away but we do have
our first scene it's not much it's just
her going into a store and buying
groceries but as you can see her hair is
completely red and of course she is
fully grown it's been speculated that
the Black Widow movie is going to take
us throughout the whole entire life of
Black Widow and see how she was trained
and raised and we probably will get a
little bit of that but there was a leak
that came out not too long ago that said
the Black Widow movie is going to take
place between the events of Captain
America Civil War and Avengers infinity
war and based on these leaked videos and
footage that seems to be the case it's
obviously not going to be after Avengers
infinity war or endgame because well we
know how that ends and it seems like
she's too old in this footage for it to
be anytime before the events of Captain
America's Civil War and it doesn't seem
like she's wearing any CGI equipment for
D aging as well so it seems like that is
the case now remember after the events
of Captain America's Civil War Black
Widow Captain America Sam and Bucky are
basically wanted by the whole entire
world they went against the sokovia
accords and even though Natasha
technically sided with Tony Stark at the
end she did help Steve Rogers get away
and we know from Avengers infinity war
and the of
infinity war prelude comic that after
the events of Civil War Steve takes
Bucky to Wakanda and then Captain
America Black Widow and Falcon go
perform missions of their own so what we
could be seen here in this footage and
in these photos is Black Widow on the
run after the events of civil war now
this is being filmed in Norway but some
reports say that this is believed to be
Natasha Romanovs home in Russia which
would make sense because if Black Widow
Captain America and Falcon had to go
hide somewhere
Black Widow would probably have a home
that's off-the-grid and unfortunately we
don't really have any much more context
about this leaked footage and photos and
we don't really have any context about
the movie as well technically Marvel
hasn't even really announced a black
widow movie yet because remember Marvel
Studios President Kevin Feige said that
nothing about the future of the MCU and
phase four is going to be announced
until after spider-man far from home as
in theaters with everybody speculating
that they're going to announce something
about the future of the MCU at San Diego
comic-con so we have a little bit over a
month until anything official about
phase four of them so you comes out from
Marvel but obviously as you can see this
is leaked footage of the movie and the
first that we got of phase four so it's
getting really exciting the next chapter
of the MCU phase four has started
production and has started filming so
let me know how excited you are in the
comments down below and let me know how
excited you are to finally see a solo
black widow movie something that a lot
of people have been waiting for for a
very long time be sure to let me know
your thoughts and be sure to keep an eye
out for my giveaway winner announcement
video later on today and like I said of
course I'm starting a new giveaway when
I hit four hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers and five hundred thousand
subscribers I'll be giving away more
Marvel Legends series collection items
plus more so be sure to subscribe to my
channel like the video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain so you can
enter the giveaway and stay up to date
on everything relating to the MCU again
thank you all so much for four hundred
thousand subscribers and thank you all
so much for watching woof woof
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby now
you're a number